[Music]
thank you
foreign
to our program I like to know I am
Daniel Miranda associate speaker for
secrets and sealed some TV and some TV
Latino
and today I am not in the presence of my
colleagues for personal reasons that
cannot be with us in this program but we
are in the presence of the Holy Spirit
and in the presence of Jesus so we'll
try to do our best to answer your
questions
before we begin this program I'd like to
remind you that you can send your
questions to the following email address
if you want to participate of this
program and the address is TV at some
tv.org again TV at some
tv.org as we have mentioned in our
previous programs this is one of our
favorite programs because we have the
opportunity to interact with you to know
what is going on in your mind and
to be able to dig deeper into the
scriptures as we try to find answers to
your questions
so before I begin I want to bow my head
in order to pray and I would plead that
you do so with me let's pray
dear heavenly father we're Charing
heaven we thank you very much for this
program and thank you for the questions
that we have received
I realized that I cannot answer them by
myself and I need the guidance of the
Holy Spirit as I do so we pray all these
things in the name of Jesus Amen
the first question that we have for
today's program comes from inara siani
and this question has to do with country
living I'm going to read the question
he says Ellen White mentions all of the
time in her writings that we should flee
the cities to reside in the countryside
my question is what if you aren't in the
position to purchase a home
what will happen if you're stuck in the
cities
I know God will help with Earnest prayer
and Faith but as a young married couple
with three small children no formal
education and a system that makes it
harder and harder to buy a home
it is starting to get a little worrisome
none of my family members have a country
home either so staying with someone when
trouble hits is not in the picture at
the moment this is a very very good and
important question and lately in these
past two years we've been getting more
and more questions in regards to country
living and I realized that because of
the events that are happening in the
world right now
covet and pandemic the war people
realize the importance of the councils
that we find the spirit of Prophecy in
regards to leaving the cities well I am
glad that I can answer this question
because
I myself
have been living in the country for the
past 12 years with a few exceptions
sometimes that I had to work in the
cities doing Ministry
so I have studied this subject quite
abundantly and Ellen White even though
she writes a lot about country living
she says she uses an expression over and
over as far as possible
God knows that not everyone will be able
to leave the cities at least now now we
know that there will come a time that it
will be the last opportunity to leave
the cities and that's when the Sunday
law comes but that time hasn't arrived
yet
and yet even though the Sunday law
hasn't come
we encourage and God encourages us to
leave the cities and make provision
because when the Sunday law comes you
won't be able to make that provision it
will be just a time to flee but not to
leave the cities and that is a an
important decision that we need to make
it is very different
to leave the cities than to flee the
cities because when you flee you don't
make provision you're just fleeing for
your life if you will
but when you leave the cities with
prayer with adequate plans then you can
make provision for your family provision
for your home
you have time to grow your own food but
when the Sunday law comes that will be
just a time to to flee therefore the
councils encourage us to leave the
cities now now in your case sister in
Nara I understand
the situation and God understands it
even more
so the idea would be that where you are
you do your best live Faithfully to God
live a healthy lifestyle even though the
idea will be the country but yet where
you are follow the a laws of Health
share your faith with others because
sometimes we think of country living and
we think of that as an isolating
ourselves from others but actually it
does not the purpose of country living
yes there are benefits in being in
contact with nature we can
behold and contemplate The Works of God
and we can have a healthier and safer
environment especially for you that have
children it will be ideal but yet if you
can't God will understand and God will
make provision for you now if as a
family you have the opportunity to go to
a self-supporting school as volunteers
to learn about country living God might
open other doors for you
I come from South America Colombia and I
work at a school called Las Delicias
where we receive volunteers there and um
they would go they did not have any
experience with country living they
would go there learn how to live in the
country because it is not just having a
different location but it's a whole
different lifestyle
and if you want to grow your own food
it's better that you have previous
experience so that when you go by
yourself you know you may not be
disappointed that is very wise if you
can have experience with other people
who already know about country living
so my con my counsel for you is pray
work and wait that would be my counsel
for you pray that God May provide a way
of Escape
wait for the best time but at the same
time while waiting do not be idle and
work there is a quote from Sister white
that she mentions in the review on
Herald I don't have it here with me I
was trying to remember when I read it
but you can email me directly and I can
try to find that question for you that
that quote for you Ellen White says that
God will not open the way for those or
for some who want to leave the cities
until they are doing their best they
they can where they are to reach souls
for Jesus
so where you are do your best to reach
souls for Jesus Christ
you also mentioned that what will happen
if you are stuck in the cities again if
you are faithful to God even when the
crisis comes
God already has other people living in
the sea in the country already and these
places will be like Cities of Refuge for
those who were not able to live before
the time
but now are living I hope I can I could
answer your question
and I'm going to move to the following
question
and this question from comes from
cyanide
isaka sayoni isaka the question is about
tithing and this is how the question
goes hello my question is if God is not
about money
then why do we go to work and pay him
tithes
that is a very important question a
question that many people have asked
themselves before so let me quote a few
texts from the Bible let's go to the
book of haggai chapter 2 verse 8. this
is uh in the section that we call the
Minor Prophets
the book of haggai chapter 2 verse 8
this is God speaking and this is what
the Bible says the silver is mine
and the gold is mine says the Lord of
hosts so you're right
God doesn't have any need of resources
because he says that the silver is his
and the gold is his so if he owns
everything why does he ask us to return
to him a tent of our income
well
when we understand the principle of
Tiding we realize that Tiding is not for
God it is for our own benefit in other
words when we tithe we're the ones that
are being benefited
is not God tithing doesn't change God's
heart tithing changes our own heart
for example
when we read in Proverbs chapter 3 verse
9.
this is about tithes and offerings
Proverbs chapter 3
verse 9. why do we tithe
here the Bible says
honor the Lord with your possessions and
with the first fruits of all your
increase
so when we tithe again and give
offerings to God this is a way of
honoring God why because some 24 1 says
that the Earth is the Lord's and the
fullness thereof because he owns
everything not only the Earth but the
cows and a thousand hills the silver and
the gold as we mentioned because
everything belongs to him then when we
return
emir pittance because this is really a
pittance this is just something really
small in compared to everything he gives
us but when we return that to him we are
acknowledging that he is our creator
that he owns what we have and we're
honoring him with part of that which he
gives us so it is a way of honoring God
and there is a promise
uh in verse 10 the following text
Sawyer Barnes will be filled with plenty
in your Vats will overflow with new wine
so who gets the benefit
we get the benefit God could rain gold
and silver from heaven and just provide
all the means that we need in order to
finish the work
but that would not be so
educational for us
because God knows that this the heart
the human heart is so selfish therefore
he established the Tiding system to
check the selfishness of our hearts
because
one of the things that our hearts are
more attached to is to money
and God strikes of one of the roots of
all sins as the Bible says the Love of
Money
is the root of all sin
so God
shoots up at our heart he knows the
selfishness of our hearts and therefore
he has this systematic plan of giving
returning to him what is his
so that
our selfishness our natural selfishness
may be checked by the tithing practice
also we read in Malachi chapter 3 verses
8 through 10.
this is a well-known text and oftentimes
it is quoted when we collect the tithes
and offerings
here in Malachi chapter 3 verses 8
through 10
we we read another reason why God asked
us to give him the tithes and offerings
will a man rob God
yet you have robbed me but you say in
what way have we robbed you in tithes
and offerings
you're cursed with a curse for you have
robbed me even this whole nation and
then verse 10 says bring all the tides
into the storehouse that there may be
food in my house
and try me now in this says the Lord of
hosts
if I will not open for you the windows
of heaven and pour out for you such a
blessing that there will be no room
enough to receive it
so several things that we we see here
first of all we tithe also so that God's
house may be full
so that there may be food in his house
so in ancient times in in Old Testament
times the tithing was brought into the
century and the tithing was used to
support the priests
and the priest were the ones doing God's
work okay in this this is referred to
where it says that my house may be full
or that there may be food in my house
again God can't provide that but God
established the Titan system so that we
can be benefited and also his work can
be benefited by it the second thing we
see here is that God wants us to prove
him as other versions say like the King
James or here in this version it says
and um and
and try me
try me now in this says the Lord prove
me try me
tithing strengthens our faith because we
trust that when we give him what is his
he will be faithful and he will return
unto us tenfold more blessings now we
shouldn't do it thinking of the reward
that he is going to give us in return we
should do it because we love him and
because we recognize that all we have
comes from him and to him it should go
so this is the reason why God
encourages actually this is a command
He commands us to tithe to return to him
the tides and offerings okay I hope this
question was answered
so the next question
I am not going to mention the name
because it's a very personal question
but at the same time this may be the
case of other people
who may be struggling with the same
things this is a person that is uh 36
years old
and the person is struggling with sin
for a while
specifically with the sin of adultery
and fornication
the person explains that when he's with
the spouse
he the is controlled by the sexual
desire and is thinking of other people
other than the spouse in order to be
aroused and and enjoy his time
so
the person wants to know
how to be free from this terrible
sin
there is a struggle here because
there is fasting there is prayer there
is study of the Bible but nothing seems
to change
and there is just too much in this
person's mind that is bringing the
person into slavery of sin
well I can tell you that many you are
not the only one many are struggling
with similar sins
and we might not be struggling with
sexual sins we may be struggling with
other other Temptations
that are the same because sin before God
is the same
what I see here in this case
and you know the person that wrote this
question and I hope that you're
listening and you're watching this
program
you know what is right
you know the will of God
and the fact that you feel bad about
what you're doing tells me that the Holy
Spirit hasn't given up on you
because or else
you will be hardened and you will be
excused in sin but I see a sincere
desire in you to overcome this
particular sin and I can assure you that
God is going to give you Victory now
what is the problem because you say I
quote the Bible I pray I fast I isolate
from people try to make things better
and then for a while things are going
good but then I fall again and now
things are even worse than before
and I don't know what to do I think I am
losing the battle
Ellen White wrote a letter and actually
this is a letter to a young man
and the case of this man is very similar
to yours and notice where the problem is
this is the key why you are not having
Victory and also for some of you who
might be listening to our program you
might be struggling with a different sin
other than adultery and you keep praying
about it and you don't seem to have
victory over this sin this is the
problem we're going to see I'm quoting
from testimonies volume Five
and write this page
513 I would encourage you to read the
entire chapter it's very powerful it's a
personal letter of Ellen White to a
young name
that is struggling with sin and doesn't
know how to overcome it
this is what she says you are a young
man of intelligence
you desire to make your life
such as will fit you for heaven at last
so this is a person that wants to do
good like the man of Romans 7. he wants
to be fitted for heaven
you are often discouraged at finding
yourself weak in moral power
in slavery to doubt and controlled by
the habits and customs of your old life
and sin
you'll find your emotional nature and
Truth to yourself
to your best resolutions and to your
most solemn pledges
nothing seems real
your own stability leads you to doubt
the sincerity of those who would do good
to you
the more you struggle in doubt the more
unreal everything looks to you
until it seems that there is no Solid
Ground for you anywhere
your promises are like ropes of sand
in your Regard in the same unreal light
the words and works of those in whom you
should trust
you will be in constant Peril this is
the key here
you will be in constant Peril until you
understand the true force of the will
so what is the problem
what is the problem with many of us who
might be struggling with sin and and we
just promise God that we're not going to
do it again but we do it again and we
even have good
uh reasons and good motives to stop
sinning
but yet we find ourselves again in the
same situation what is the problem the
problem is that we are not understanding
the true force of the will
we when we pray we think that God will
do for us what we can do for ourselves
just a simple example
you might ask for purity of mine but if
you keep watching pornography you will
never have the victory if you keep
allowing your eyes to go into wrong
directions looking at other women who
are not your who is not your wife
or who is not your husband
then you are not doing the part that is
yours and God will never do for you
now temptation is not sin you may feel
the pull you may feel the urge
um and these Poland or this urge is
stronger if in the past you have
cherished you have encouraged this
sinful practices in other words if in
the past you watch pornography or you
were involved in different sexual
practices then the the the inclinations
are strengthened and therefore some
people for some people
fighting against temptation is even more
difficult than others because they have
indulged in sin for longer and in more
repetitive ways but if you stop where
you are
and you choose not to defile yourself
with that you will gain the victory the
thought might come
the pool may come but immediately you
need to reject it now the exercise of
the wheel even though it is in our own
power
we need to strengthen the will by Prayer
by studying the Bible by having good
lifestyle because if we don't then our
wheels are weakened uh one a few things
that weaken our will
not going to bed early enough not
sleeping well not resting not doing
exercise eating things that affect our
body and our minds so when the minds are
clouded and are not in the best physical
condition then it is more difficult for
us to put our Wheels in God's will in
God's Direction
but yet
even though this is our part
we know that we cannot do it by
ourselves
we need to trust God and have faith that
he will give us the victory I'll I'll
finish the quote
it says you may believe and promise all
things
but your promises are or your faith
are of no value listen to this
you might have faith
you might have promised thanks to God
but your promises or your faith are on
no value until you put your will on this
side of Faith and Action on the side of
what of Faith and Action so you have to
act if you fight the fight of Faith with
all your willpower you will conquer your
feelings your impressions your emotions
are not to be trusted
for they are not reliable especially
with your perverted ideas and the
knowledge of your broken promises and
your forfeited pledges weakens your
confidence in yourself
and the faith of others in you
so I believe this is exactly what is
happening to you
um let me just share a few verses before
we close let's go to Romans
how to do your part what is our part
okay we said our part is to exercise our
Wheels but there are other things that
we also need to do
Romans chapter 13.
and I'm going to read the last verse of
this chapter Romans chapter 13.
the Bible says but put on the Lord Jesus
Christ
and make no provision for the flesh to
fulfill its lusts
what does it say make no provision for
the flesh how do you make provision for
the flesh
you put yourself
in places or in situations that uh
awaken the evil that is in your heart
you look at things and that people that
women or at men that you are not
supposed to look you watch pornography
um you commit or practice secret sin or
secret advice
any of these things strengthen the
animal Passions
and you're making provision for the
Flesh and therefore when the Temptation
comes again
you find yourself weak to resist it
you should also make the prayer of
we that we find in Job chapter 30 verse
1 you should make it your prayer every
morning
you should make this
um
your prayer actually is proverbs 31
verse 1. the Bible says I have made a
covenant with my eyes
why then should I look upon a young
woman
so every morning when you get up pray
and make a covenant with your eyes that
you will not look upon a young woman
that is not your wife
also we read
in Psalm 101
again all this has to do with the
Avenues of the Soul which elleny refers
to referring to the census okay we need
to guard The Avenues of our soul
so that we do not make provision for the
flesh this is Psalm 101 and I'm going to
read verse 3. the Bible says I will set
nothing Wicked before my eyes
I hate the work of those who fall away
it shall not cling to me again here
there is this is a decision this is a
choice that I make
I will not look upon a virgin I will not
set any wicked thing before my eyes I
hope that this uh Words May encourage
you and give you
or give you tools so that you may have
the victory in Jesus Christ thank you
for being with us in this program I'd
like to know remember you can send us
your questions and we will see you next
time God bless you
[Music]
foreign